[Music]
hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
Brianne Chandler over here I was just
telling Brianne about how we do a
segment here called trailers revisited
and we found the top requested one from
our latest trailers revisited was the
matrix a movie that we have both I've
seen it yes many times I've seen it it's
my favorite movie of all time is it my
favorite movie of all time is that and
white chicks oh yeah I feel like that's
a great social commentary on our society
yeah it's just like the matrix just now
yeah you got to watch watch it anyway
yeah we're gonna do the matrix there's
no gray quality version of this trailer
online I've tried searching I must have
seen the Jennifer the matrix when I was
like a kid I can't recall it all what
the trailers like I don't remember
anything about it I think what I
remember is feeling like it's gonna be a
horror movie I don't know what
impression I had when I first saw it I'm
sure that I saw it I don't remember
seeing it but I'm sure I probably
thought science fiction let's of course
there's a science fiction let's do it
rated R for our stuff before they told
you when I was our
[Music]
[Music]
famous line overhead a dream the other
that she was so sure it was real she
look like a movie to wake from that
dream how would you know the difference
between the dream world what is
happening to me the answer is out there
neo it's the question that drives us The
Matrix is in the world that has been
pulled over your eyes to blind you from
the truth I love this movie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Dorothee
[Music]
oh this is the song on the main menu
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it so the movie and all that what
is the matrix com I find him way more
fascinating to go back to trailers from
like a couple decades ago or whatever it
reminds me of what people were
anticipating at the time and what led to
it being so successful that closing line
right there no one can be told what the
matrix is you have to see it for
yourself because if you think about it
when you're watching this trailer you
know if you haven't seen the matrix like
I don't get what the hell this is what
is going on you don't know but knowing
the plot now you're like they showed you
everything they cover a lot of the movie
but they don't necessarily break down
ABCD how it's all gonna go down like who
exactly is neo and the computer hacker
and it's definitely not an order in any
sort of way
no but they glimpse a lot of the movie
they take a lot of cool imagery what I
find really fascinating about this
trailer there's like almost no martial
arts in the trailer and that was the big
thing that people were talking about
when the movie came out I was after the
matrix where everyone was required to
learn how to do martial arts no matter
what action here you were gonna be terms
of learning how to actually fistfight
and do kicks and stuff it was the matrix
it started that we started having like
copycats after the matrix so I'm really
surprised you don't really see martial
arts in here like you don't really see
the dojo fight you see a glimpse of the
dojo and that's it yeah you see like a
lot of Rosie yeah there's a whole train
fight between him and agency and so it
makes me wonder like what the marketing
team thought this movie would be like is
that was the biggest surprise I think
that everyone had when they walked out
was whoa Keanu Reeves Laurence Fishburne
they can really fight in this movie
because they're doing crazy martial arts
in it that was the whole big thing is
they have to take like six months to
learn how to fight I'm kind of surprised
it didn't feature any of that in this
trailer well though they train hours and
hours and hours every day and like
Dancing with the Stars yeah yeah
doing it all day the matrix is like
Dancing with the stock show that one
image towards the end where they both
have the guns oh yeah like you're empty
what I thought they did really well at
doing was actually hyping up carrie anne
moss
if there's nothing to give away it's
like most of carrie anne moss is coolest
tricks
yeah like when she runs up the wall and
cartwheels off of it when she does this
jumps across the rooftop so it actually
leads her to be more of this like
mystique big year that is kind of her
role in the movie but it's a little bit
it's easier laid out in the film i think
you know it was bigger question as to
who's Morpheus and who's neo and all
that period mosses the you know the love
interest who knows like a bunch of
really bad as martial arts and stuff
yeah and then they show their kiss so
you know that she's gonna be the love
interest yeah it kind of gives that away
man her whole thing with the oracle in
the movie is you'll fall in love with
the one so you'll know it's the one when
you fall in love with the dude
[Music]
that was just a metaphorical thing like
oh the one the way when you watch the
trailer she looks like she'd be the one
who's kicking the most ass in the film
and she kicks a lot of ass in the movie
I'm just so surprised I don't show you
that Keanu Reeves and Laurence Fishburne
and Hugo Weaving are also throwing down
and then the trailer they show you a lot
of gun moments but I think there's more
martial arts than there is gun action in
the thing for a 90s show that's not cut
bad they want to show you those big
action set-pieces they're like we paid a
lot of money for this yeah you're not
gonna go see this movie cuz you don't
know what the matrix is
yeah so therefore we're gonna show you
what we have we're gonna lay our cards
out on the table so then wait you can
decide if you're gonna come I think
what's brilliant about this marketing
cuz normally when we watch these shows
I'm like look how misleading it is but
it's not misleading and if anything it's
really smart and how they did it in
terms of like their website name their
domain name what is the matrix exists
website is currently not available but
is one owned by Warner Brothers
thanks Warner you know you look at
movies like annihilation and whether the
big thing was like this movies not
marketed right audiences wouldn't be
able to understand anihilation so we're
gonna give it just a release in the US
but other countries just a you know
straight to Netflix because audiences
aren't intelligent enough to understand
it but I remember when the matrix came
out so many people will walk out of this
going I don't know what it's about but
it's really cool but the trailer is not
misleading in that because the trailer
doesn't tell what lineout trailer
doesn't tells you just go try to figure
it out for yourself that's what they're
telling you in the trailer is if you
want to know what this movie is of what
it's about you have to go watch it as
they use that brilliant line from
Morpheus so I think that's really clever
marketing cuz it's actually not a
misleading trailer it's not like I watch
this trailer going I think I'm gonna get
a very specific film i watch this
trailer and I'm like I'm kind of
confused what it's about but it looks
really appealing you know pleasantly
surprised by that man pleasantly
surprised by this trailer really holds
up it holds up and I think it holds up
pretty well I mean it's a little
fast-paced but then the movies not
exactly slow so you know whatever
watching
just thinking gosh there's a lot that
happens in this how much we don't even
see in that dream yeah if this movie
came out today it would be a hard ass
movie to market right yes I think about
it need the rock Orpheus part I think in
terms of story wise it'd be hard to
market yes
like Studios would be like we don't know
through this movie how the hell are we
marking this so I'm surprised that in
the 90s they knew how to market it smart
enough to know how to get people hooked
into what is the story and then also get
hooked by the spectacle really a job
Warner Brothers I hope you still make
good trailers like this in the future
well what are the recommendations you
guys have this was a great
recommendation didn't even consider it
so thank you please put down
recommendations for us you guys don't
see white chicks don't do white chicks I
don't want to be misled you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification about get notified every
time one of our vids is Brienne Chandler
is on Miss movies YouTube channel go
check her out there follow her social
media as well and check us out on
patreon weekly q and A's full-length TV
show music video reactions over there a
whole bunch of goodies actually go check
it out
love you guys